with great franchising comes great
responsibility
[Music]
new trailer for spider-man into the
spider-verse now I talked about the
first trailer for this a little while
back and was mostly positive on it I
didn't really know what to make of it
though cuz that was mostly a
presentation of visual style and we
didn't get a lot of sense of the
characters or the story or anything else
here we're getting more of that and the
first thing I will say is I'm totally on
board with this visual style now it was
a little bit weird for me first time
scene because I think for that exact
reason it was my first time seeing it
and I wasn't sure what to make of it
within 5 seconds of this trailer I
didn't even notice sort of the
choppiness of the movement anymore it
just completely float it looked natural
looked right so I'm now totally on board
for that there is almost nothing I don't
really like about this trailer firstly
I'm really excited to see Miles Morales
because it had been my hope when it was
announced that Spiderman was going to be
introduced into the MCU that they were
going to do Miles Morales rather than
give us our third crack at Peter Parker
in relatively recent memory so I want to
see Miles Morales and then if I'm being
completely honest I don't know what Tana
well I know a bit about him I have read
hardly any of his stuff I never really
gotten to the ultimate spider-man stuff
what little I read was before he was
introduced as a character but I've
always liked the idea of him so I've
always been eager to see him execute it
so I can get more a sense of him as a
character what I see I dig I dig a lot I
really like the relationship he has with
his parents especially his father
because that right there is a nice
serious distinction between him and
Peter because Peter has you know a very
loving but not parental not directly
parental relationship with his Aunt May
and it's very much of a broken home his
parents are dead his uncle is dead
whereas this kid has a loving family and
you get to have a whole new home dynamic
and a whole new sort of building the
foundation of a character in terms of
explaining why he would take on the
mantle of somebody like spider-man
I'll be really curious to see how the
needle gets thread in terms of all this
and I think it was very smart that it
sounded like and I wouldn't be surprised
if this was said just for the trailer
and isn't even from the film but like if
the whole thing where it's it's like
he's saying to the audience in your
universe there's only one Spider Man
here there's more than one like simple
to the point so anyone in the audience
going wait a minute and can go oh okay
we're dealing with a whole other cool so
I think that was good because look let's
be honest most mainstream people don't
know who the hell Miles Morales is so
that was wrong really smart move from a
marketing standpoint and the you know
the flow of this thing the look of the
action the interactions the jokes all of
it is it's firing on all cylinders for
me the one thing that made me doesn't
quite get there for me is Peter I think
the thing is and and maybe part of it is
the voice also really reminds me of TJ
Miller I looked it up it's not him but
it's it cuz it sounds very slacker
ish which is not how I ever think of
people like there are a lot of different
ways to envision Peter you know Tobey
Maguire may not have been my preference
on playing Peter but the way he played
Peter is a very valid way to play Peter
and as is how Tom Holland plays I'm
honestly so is how Andrew Garfield
played him again even though I didn't
love that all the time but this sort of
we're lazy doesn't have money is really
into a sandwich I know it that's one of
the things where I think you feel sort
of the Lord and Miller influence a
little bit on this cuz that that's
that's it feels like where a character
has been altered for the sake of a joke
and I I tiny tangent I have to wonder if
that's the kind of approach that got
them booted off of so low I don't know
that's speculative but that's really my
only nitpick and even that I'm hoping
even if I don't love this Peter it won't
drag it down cuz I'm hoping the focus
properly on miles it to me it looks like
it will be I mean we get a little
glimpse of spider-gwen
which is another character that I like
in theory and love the design I love her
costume I think that it's the coolest
freakin thing ever but I've never
I haven't read her stuff yet it's it's
like it
her stuff at the very least is on the
docket for the punch like a girl podcast
that I do with Liz no idea when we're
going to get to it so I will read that
eventually but I that's another
character I'm excited to see realize and
part of me at that revealed the
variables like is that kind of spoiler
that we see that but I will bet you we
are gonna get a ton more spider people
spider-man variants beyond that I I will
lay down money right now like that we
will see spider-man noir and Miguel
O'Hara is right around 2099 and
spider-ham and I bet we get way more
maybe maybe we get Mayday Parker's
brighter girls so you know I think I
think that I expect that seeing
spider-gwen will not be a massive
spoiler because she's just the tip of
the iceberg so yeah that just about
doesn't voice cast is really good on
this from the ones that we heard and
also the ones that I looked up seeing
who else's cast and even though we
didn't hear they got Liev Schreiber's
the kingpin I'm kind of kinda stoked
about that but yeah I like this a lot
which was nice because the first trailer
didn't turn me off but it didn't sell me
either I'm sold now I'm excited for this
so spider-man into the spider verse what
did you think about this trail or
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's stuff to do you do
the stuff like subscribe patreon support
you know you want to throw something my
way appreciate it bless you follow me on
Twitter or send me an email buy a
t-shirt listen to the podcast I
mentioned maybe who knows links for all
that stuff is down in the description
and some more stuff besides so until
next time this council is adjourned why
did I point I never point why am I still
doing it I need to stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]